hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar from discovery to functional
assays
therapeutic antibody research by miltoni
biotek i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and
i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by miltoni biotek to
learn more visit them at
miltneybiotech.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that support tab found at
the top right of your presentation
window
or report the problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located on the top right hand corner of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker suzanne
beaker
a global manager for be cell
at milt muldeney biotech for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen suzanne welcome you may now begin
your presentation
everyone to today's webinar it's my
great
pleasure to have you all here and
i'm really happy to give this very
webinar on therapeutic antibody research
because this is like a really
important topic to me and i hope you
enjoy it as much as i would do
so this is the agenda for today so i'll
first talk a bit about
therapeutic antibodies in
immuno-oncology in a more general way
so just a short introduction into the
topic
then i will talk about the therapeutic
antibody process
which steps are involved how is this
actually working until you really get
this therapeutic antibody the final
product that goes to the patient
and then also we talk about the
functional screening of
those antibodies because this is also
like a very important step
in this whole development process
so let's directly start into the topic
and let's talk about
therapeutic antibodies in general so
there are many
different mechanisms of action how
therapeutic antibodies can work on a
target
or like here of course a tumor cell
an antibody can bind to two more antigen
on the surface of the target cell and
induce
programmed cell death or apoptosis
we of course have other mechanisms like
an antibody can bind to soluble factors
that neutralizes those factors and block
them from binding
also an antibody can bind to a receptor
on the surface of the tumor cell
and by that a block the binding of the
soluble factors to this receptor
but also activate those receptors
then we have also the complement
dependent
cytotoxicity so an antibody can bind to
the tumor antigen
and then the c1 complex of the
complement system can bind against the
fc part of the antibody
what leads to the complement cascade and
ultimately to the formation of the
membrane attack
complex what is kind of leading to
the lysis of the tumor cell
then also we have engineered antibodies
antibodies that are conjugated
so to say it could be radiation or drugs
that are conjugated to these antibodies
and
directly targeted to the tumor cells
we have bispecific or tri-specific
antibodies so
antibodies with several specificities
bridging effector and tumor cell
together
and we have checkpoint inhibitors so
antibodies that are binding against
these immune checkpoints
and helping the immune system to act
against tumor cells
and then we of course have a very
important topic that's the effector cell
recruitment
so an antibodies again binding against
the tumor antigen
and then effector cells can bind to the
fc part of the antibody like
nk cells in using adcc
antibody dependent cellular cytotoxicity
we have macrophages that can do that
that they then do phagocytosis
or also t cells that are doing then t
cell dependent cellular cytotoxicity
so all these steps or all these like
mechanisms
can lead to tumor killing and that's why
therapeutic antibodies are
very important in the cancer field
as cancer therapeutics and you see here
also the adcc
so this antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxicity
caused by nk cells can work in different
ways so
by normally it is that you have your
antibody that's binding against the
tumor antigen
and then the fc receptor of the mk cell
binds to the fv part of the antibody but
then leads to the killing of the tumor
cell
but this can also be done with
bispecific antibodies
or also blocking antibodies are
important that block the inhibitory
receptors
of nk cells so that they can work and
kill the tumor cell so
now that that was it for my introduction
for the beginning so now we
directly hop into the topic of the whole
therapeutic antibody discovery process
and this is like yeah has several steps
so to say so you really start with the
target discovery
so with the validation so you really
want to see like you know what's the new
maybe like two more target what can we
like direct
how can we direct our therapies against
this tumor
and then of course in the next step
after you validated your target
you do the antibody discovery because of
course you want to have an antibody
against this target
in the next step you do the antibody
production so you produce those
antibodies to be able
to test them in the functionality
testing do the lead characterization
and then of course like antibody
engineering is happening because like
usually it can always like be a bit
better so you can always like do a bit
of optimization
of course then you do like functional
testing again if it's like really
working better or not
in comparison to the beginning and then
in the end
by that you select your candidate go
into clinical testing
and then you have to have your final
product that then goes into patients so
it's really a process
with a lot of steps with a lot of work
involved
and we always try to make this processes
like a bit more
easy to digest so we always try to put
that into workflows and that's like how
we actually
present our workflow how i pre represent
the workflow today to make it a bit
easier to understand
this like you know complex process i see
so we always
do that in like several steps so in our
multi-new world with the
sample preparation cell separation cell
culture
flow cytometry and now we also have
imaging and microscopy
products and instruments that also help
you with your work
and so we have a lot of products you see
here on the bottom
so i will try to explain like the
workflows in this kind of way
so let's directly start into the target
discovery in validation because this is
like also like a
very important step in this whole
process because when you don't have the
right target
it's really like complicated to work so
this
you can do with this maxima imaging
platform
that's ultra high content imaging system
where you can analyze like really
hundreds of markers
with a single sample so it's really like
an automated sampling process and
imaging process
and you can image like all types of
fixed samples from tissue
to actually single cells and here on the
left hand side you really see this like
nice picture and how it looks like so
you can really see
your tumor cells and which cells are
surrounding
the tumor where i actually like to be
cells located where are the
mk cells where did the t cell so it's
really interesting and
with this you can also find out your
targets
because you really see on your tumor
sample
where are actually our tumor antigen
and so here we did this for a
glioblastoma tumor sample
and we actually found out that actually
it is just a restricted expression
of this established markers in this
tumor so you see this like
here and here so there's actually not so
much
expression of this like commonly known
and used markers
that i also use for catis therapy
and we actually identify this like you
know four new markers a b
c and d that have higher expression
levels as you see here on the left
and also higher percentage of positive
cells and you also see this like here
in green with like two gliopastoma
samples so that really like the sample
looks like
really green in all the sample in
comparison to like you know
there's like commonly established
markers so it's really a nice way on you
how we can really like look into your
tumor
into your tumor sample and see what's
actually going on in there
so that was it like so far from this
like side step let's now
talk about how you actually discover
antibodies
how are you getting your lead candy date
and now we're hopping into like my first
workflow
so of course like you start with here
the sample preparation because you want
to have
your antibodies for maybe like a human
cancer patient
recovered patients maybe like a mouse
model and want to get
a two more hour to spleen out or maybe
you're even like starting with blood
products
you do your sample processing to get
single cells
and then you separate your b cells and
of course you want to see like do i
really got nice b
cells and do nice qc analysis
do flow analysis cultivate your b
cells because they're not like usually
not really frequent especially when
they're coming from tumor samples
and then you can select in the next step
for the binder so like
really your antigen your target positive
b cells
go into expression of your antibody
your lead candidate and really go
then into the functional testing
but actually with this workflow with
this process they're coming a lot of
challenges for you
so it can be that you have like you know
many different kits that you could use
for the b cell separation
and this is like really confusing
sometimes
also cell activation you don't want to
get activated b
cells after your b cell separation
and also like when you do single cell
sequencing the rna
quality is really important but no
worries we have a solution for all these
challenges
so i put together for you this slide so
this is like you know we have some nice
materials that show you
an overview of the b cell products
really from which starting material
can you get which subset of interest and
which kit can you use
also here i wanted to show you that cell
activation with the b
cell separation is not happening so we
couldn't find any up regulation of
activation markers in positive or in
negative isolation
so here we have the palm b cell
isolation kit and you see like
after separation the unstimulated cells
are not activated
also with the positive separation it's
looking
the same just when you add external
stimuli like cd40 ligand and il4
your b cells are getting nicely
activated as they should
another step and another like
complicated step for the b
cells is to be psych cultivation because
this is not
they're not so easy it's really time
consuming primary b
cells are not easy to cultivate
sometimes they just die they're not
growing and the expansion is not
sufficient
so that's sometimes a bit complicated
and that's
why we develop this nice human b-cell
expansion kit
that has a standardized 10-foot
expansion of your b-cells in vitru
within 14 days
it preserves all your b-cell subsets
and it's like really a standardized and
efficient activation of these health
if you want to know more about this we
made like a very nice
scientific poster about this topic
tested different
settings different cytokines
and checked for the subsets and so on so
if you want to know more about this
when you get the pdf just click here and
then you get more information on that
then the next step would be the binder
selection so you really want to have
your
target positive your antigen positive b
cells
and this is a bit tricky because it's a
very rare subset
b cells are very sensitive you don't
want to have like any contamination
or a sample carry over and also it's
like you know
high safety level acquired when you
are working with infectious materials or
depending on which patients you are
having
and there we have a very nice solution
that's like the max quantity
this very gentle microchip based uh
sorting process
what's especially advantageous for this
very sensitive b
cells it's in a closed and sterile
cartridge system so you have
no contaminate contamination no sample
carryover and also like
very safe for operators because you have
this closed cartridge
you do flow sorting based on up to 10
parameters where you can also really
nicely
uh sort resell sub populations here's
just like you know
an example of like total b cells so here
you see like your b
cells before sorting and here after
sorting what worked
really nicely so another challenge is
always like the cell analysis
so this is always a problem of
background on specific binding the
reproducibility and that it always takes
like so
long and if you want to know more about
this
please watch our webinar that we hold in
june so there's like of course a
recording available
so when you just later here click on
this link
then you can just watch the webinar
where we explain all the solutions to
these challenges
and now i come to like a conclusion of
this workflow so to say
so the kids that i would recommend you
to use
in this workflow it's
tumor dissociation kits and the
gentlemax to
do your sample preparation for the
isolation of b
cells straight from kids where you can
really directly
isolate your b-cells from blood
products in a really fast and also
possible automated manner
that really saves you a lot of time
but also like you can of course do
isolation of b
cells from pbmcs with pumpbusy isolation
kit
or also cd19 microbeads
also do cell analysis with three
affinity antibodies and also our max
current analyzer
and for the visa culture i really
recommend you our
nice b-cell expansion kit we also have
cd40 ligand multi-mag hits for human
tlr ligands and a lot a lot of cytokines
that help you with b cell culture
for the binary selection i recommend you
to use the max coin title
and then you're almost done and go to
then
expression and functional testing of
these antibodies
so now we have our need candidates okay
so now we want to know what are they
actually doing
so now functional testing is happening
for this
like lead characterization but also
for the optimization because you really
want to make them
work better and for this we have tons
of different essays so i just selected
some of them and just put them here on
the slide so that you see
there are like so many different things
that like you know an antibody can do
and that are tested but i cannot walk
you through all these like workflows and
all these
uh essays today it would take like you
know really
it would get really really late so i
just focused on two of them
so as i like you mentioned before the
adcc so the antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxicity assay and the mixed
lymphocyte
reaction that's also used a lot when
people are screening checkpoint
inhibitors and that's why i
choose that one so let's directly hop
into the topic of the adcc
so the workforce looks like this so you
also get your blood sample here in case
like of course
of a human and isolate your nk
cells you expand your nk cells
and then you go into the co-culture
of your antigen positive cancer cells
with the nk
cells and your antibody candidate
up here but you also do
the same without the antibodies to be
able to
you know like compare it where is
killing happening
and where not and then of course
afterwards you have the readout
with the flow cytometry and really check
for anexin
or pi to really see where is the killing
happening
so what is going on there what does the
antibody do
challenges can be here also of course
selectivation and cell separation that
you
sometimes have like really low volumes
of blood because you have like you know
patients or clinical samples maybe so
there's sometimes maybe not like so much
then the nkt cell contamination
that sample that is possible and that
like you know automation because like
people are doing like tons of this essay
several of these assets not only the
adcc's
one maybe also like you know all of the
other ones that i showed you before
the automation is like really important
here
so and i just wanted to show you here
that all this is first
without our kids so with the straight
from buffy code
cd56 microbeads you can isolate your nk
cells directly from blood
what saves you a lot of time and can
also be done in an
automated manner but of course you can
also use the nk
cell isolation kit so isolate your nk
cells from pbmcs and also do that in an
automated way
in both cases you get nicely
isolated non-activated nk cells
of course with the dd56 microbeads you
also get
the mkt cells but it doesn't really
matter
in this in this essay because they have
no
fcr receptors mkt says do next
dot express cd16 so
no antigen binding antibody binding can
happening
and say so they do not interfere in this
essay
so it really doesn't matter and i show
you the data here
so here's the comparison of this natural
cytotoxicity in comparison to adccc
with ourselves isolated with both kids
so with the straight from kids and
untouched and the killing is really
happening
nicely and just like looks the same no
matter if you're doing
straight from or untouched and here we
just like use different
ratios of cells so if you want to know
more about the adcc
essay please later click in the pdf
on this here we have a nice application
note
what explains all the details and all
the data that you need to know about
adcc
and these are the products i recommend
you for
this essay so i told you before the
straight from microbeads
to isolate your anchor cells from whole
blood buffy code leukopeg or lasc
then also the mk cell isolation kits
with the isolation
of nk cells from pbmcs
then nk max medium and max cytokines and
here the nk
max medium is like really great because
it helps you that
your mk cells are not getting exhausted
because that's sometimes what happens at
nksi
culture but with the nk max medium this
is really not happening
and then for the readout you of course
have a lot of reaffinity antibodies and
the max quant analyzer
where you can analyze the readout of
your
killing essays in the adcc and with the
max quantix this can also be done in an
automated way works really nicely
and now we come into the second essay so
now we are talking about the mixed
lymphocyte reaction
what i told you is more done for the
checkpoint inhibitors
so this is an essay that's like
sometimes
really a bit yeah confusing because
because it can be done in many different
ways
and that's why sometimes a bit dead like
yeah people are
saying mlr to like many different things
and so we put together like you know
here three options that you can do
so option one is so you're getting your
pbmcs from donor one
and mix them with pbmcs from donor two
but you can also do option two mix the t
cells from donor one
with the antigen presenting cells from
donor two
but you could also do an mri it's also
an mr1 you mix just like the t
cells of donor one and donor two you mix
them all together
here in the tissue culture add them your
lead candidate your antibody checkpoint
inhibitor
and then you look for proliferation and
activation here now i will focus on
option two so mixing the t cells with
the antigen presenting cells
the workflow looks like this so you have
donal number one
and donor number two and go into
monocyte and t cell isolation
and for your monocytes you need to
differentiate
them into monocyte derived dendritic
cells so to say more disease
in culture and then you have your
antigen presenting cells your
body sees you may extend the modifies
with your t-cells
in culture at your lead candidate
your antibody and then you're going
directly
after a bit of culture into the
proliferation essay
and check in the flow for activation
and proliferation
challenges can be here that yeah
sometimes the modi sees have a
suboptimal
antigen stimulation yeah inconsistent
cell culture result is sometimes almost
like a problem
also here with demodicies and also
difficult translation into clinics
but don't worry i have also like
solution here
so with the max premium we get cytokines
you can really
optimally differentiate and maturate
your modifies
so we could really show that they are
like you know
getting into a mature phenotype
that their migration capacity
is really working nicely and also that
they produce
il-12 so really all the criteria that
you need for your modi sees
and with this exact unit per microgram
those thing that we have with our
premium grade cytokines
you always stimulate your modi sees
in the right way so you're really doing
always
using the same activity so to say so
you're not putting in like one time much
more than the other time
so it's like always like really
standardized and always the same
so here you see some example data how
mlr is looking like
and if you're interested in like more
details and
more data more explanation just like
click later here
on this application know that we did on
the mlr
essays the products i would recommend
you here
are this also this straight from product
so we
have them for b cells we have them for t
cells we have them for nk cells
and also like you know for the monocytes
so cd14 microbeads cd4
cd8 microbeads so also again
directly getting yourself from
whole blood from buffy comb from lrc
and from luco park what saves you a lot
of time and can be automated
then of course we have like all these
kits where you can isolate your cells
from pbmcs
so cd4 cd8 cd 3
cd 14 micro beats and also
the untouched kits for t-set isolation
and
monocyte isolation kit so you can really
select here
what fits your project what fits your
needs the best
to select really here the product that
you want to have
and then in the step of cultivation and
moduc differentiation
you can use the max premium gate
cytokines il4
and gmcsf to really differentiate
your modicis for the t cells
i would recommend you the tex max medium
that is really like a great medium for t
cells what gives you
high expansion of t cells so it's really
nice
and for the reason out of course the
reaffinity antibodies have all you need
to
really get your proliferation analysis
done
and with the max point analyzer you can
you have to dice read out and as i told
you before with the max quantix
this can also be done in a very nice
automated way so that
this is like really done while you maybe
like go back to
your office and drink a cup of coffee or
listen to
a nice webinar that we are doing
so in summary i just wanted to tell you
and i hope i made it clear to you that
immuno oncology assets are really
important tools for the development
assess and assessment of novel
therapeutic antibody
candidates and we really support you
with the entire workflow of the
therapeutic antibody discovery process
with simple standardized optimized and
automated solutions and not
only for this essays and applications i
showed you here so there's like much
more and
i hope we hope that i could help you and
that we can help you
to fight such diseases as cancer and of
course
also infectious diseases as
vasco too and now i thank you very much
so that's like
yeah the disclaimer and i thank you very
much for
your attention
thank you suzanne for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in suzanne
our first question is which media did
you use
in the adcc assay and the b
cell culture
ah okay thank you very much for that
first question
and i'm really sorry that you had to
wait for this answer so long
so actually these are two different
media
so for the adcc essay we have a specific
nk cell media that's called nk
max media that has a specific
like you know consumption and like a lot
of like
additives that are really specifically
made for the nk
cells and we actually found out that
specifically
for this essay this is really useful
because we had some discussion with
customers that actually explained
us that when they culture the nk cells
they afterwards they are like a bit
you're tired they don't work
you know anymore that nicely they don't
kill anymore that nicely so that's
called
yeah mainly like you know exhaustion of
nk cells
and we could really show that with our
media this exhaustion
of the nk cells is not happening so that
they
are staying awake so that they're really
doing their job in the essay so that
they can really
kill nicely in the b cell culture
it of course looks different so these
cells are a bit
yeah complicated to culture
and also very sensitive so they don't
get exhausted they just
usually die when they're not cultured in
the right way
or not in a sensitive way enough and
that's why we actually like have a very
nice media or like you know it's a kit
the b cell expansion kit that
is belongs there are three different
components in we have a
specific media with a lot of cytokines
inside and then also the cd40 ligand
multimeter that cross-links the cd40
receptor on the surface of the b cells
that would usually be done by the help
of the t
cells and then also added different
cytokines for instance il4
is in this kit to really like you know
push the expansion of the b
cells because that would usually also be
produced
by the t cell so the b cells like the
hab and that's why we're trying to mimic
with this kid
and the help of the t cells and that
really helps nicely with your culture
and you get nice expansion rates there
on top of course like we have a specific
media for the thesis but you didn't ask
for that but you know you also that you
have heard it
i mentioned it before already that we
have this like
a tax max media very funny name but also
really good media for the t
cells so we have everything that you
need for your essays
thank you very much and our next
question from our audience
is in the context of that abcc
will it be possible to modify the fc
portion of the antibody in order to
increase
the binding to cd16
oh actually that's a very good question
as well because this is something that
is
is actually like you know discussed a
lot recently so i went to several
conferences on antibodies this year and
this was actually like
yeah also very hot topic that i found
very inspiring so they're really like
people
working on this right now so you can
of course modify the fc portion of the
antibody
and they found out when they used
different fc parts different
glucosylation
patterns and all these different things
that they could
increase the binding to cd16 so this fc
receptor and there even found out that
different fc receptors are pushing the
nk cells even a bit more so that when
you have like you know
also like another fc part and it binds
to a slightly different
c receptor and then the nk cells are
even more activated in killing
so there's a lot of research going on
there right now and
even like you know the libraries that
are done to like you know screen all the
fc
factor functions so this is really a
very
yeah amazing and very interesting topic
actually
thank you so much and now can the
positive selection needs be removed
prior to the assays
yeah this is actually like a very
interesting topic because that's also
like technique that is like
pretty new and that we have since like
just like a couple of years
so that we call the release technology
so to release the beats so uh
by this you can actually add this
micro beads like you know normal cd19
cd4 cd8 cd56
micro beats to your bbmcs
isolate your you know your cells of
that you want to have pieces pieces and
cases whatever says you want to have
and then um you actually add
a yeah specific reagent that actually
competes with the beads
for binding against the cell so that
those uh beads are then binding
to the reagents you add there so that
you actually remove
the whole bead and also
um that the beads are getting digested
it's all like you know in the same step
so by that you get completely label free
cells so we actually could
show in several examples and several
experiments that really the whole cells
are like you know free and you can stay
in them really nicely they're not
affected by this whole process
so they're not getting activated
and by this you can like still use the
very same marker used for separation
then also later on for analysis so this
is
actually i think like a very nice
technique
thank you so much susanna we have time
for one more question
our final question from an audience can
you explain more about the
untouched versus straight form workflow
reagents
okay yeah so the untouched uh
kids are like you know the kids that we
usually use uh like all the
isolation kids so with this kids you
label the cells that you don't
want to have in your isolation so as i'm
like you know the b cell
product manager i would like explain it
for b cells all
the non-b cells are labeled then and in
the cycle of fraction so then you would
label like
n cases the t says all the dendritic
cells monocytes all this like cells that
you don't want to have also of course
like you know
some of the maybe remaining blood cells
in your pbmc
samples and they are then retained in
the magnetic field in the column
and by this just the b cells that are
unlabeled so
untouched flow to the column and then
you end up
with your uncharged label-free cells
and in the straight from technology it's
a bit different
because there you go for a positive
isolation so here in the b-side case
again
with cd19 microbeads so that you
directly label
the cells of interest but this is done
directly in your blood product so to say
we have it for
but lrc buffy code
the cone we have it also for bone marrow
especially like we know for the b cells
it's interesting for to get plasma
sessors
also out of the bone marrow so you
directly add the beads
to your sample you don't have to process
it you don't have to do pbmc
isolation what's you know you all know
it takes a lot of time and it's not
really fun to do it
so you can really directly add the beads
to your sample
and then do the isolation out of this
sample
directly but of course this has to be
done in a
yeah direct and positive way so that's
like you know why use that like you know
cd19 cd56 cd4 cd8
to isolate your cells and very
interesting is also this can be
also also as the untouched kids be
automated
and in this way you can also nicely
isolate
several subsets of cells
from the same sample what's i think like
a really nice
advantage there so that you can precede
several things one after another so that
you first isolate the b cells and then
you
still have the remaining cells because
you did like positive isolation and then
you go for the nk cells next then for
the t
cell sex and that saves you really a lot
of time and i think it's like great
too especially for this kind of workflow
where you look into so many different
cell types and you want to have them all
and of course you want to save your
precious sample
thank you so much suzanne thank you for
your presentation today would you like
to provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we go
yeah of course thank you all very much
that you were so patient with me
and that we had such a nice webinar
today i really enjoyed it very much and
i hope you find like you know all the
solutions that you need for the
functional
essays that you want to do with your
therapeutic antibody research
and i think that as it was such a nice
thing we're
going to do a next one next year with
more detailed uh
details and more essays i'm looking
forward to
and thank you again suzanne beaker for
your time today
for your important research and i also
want to take the opportunity to thank
labrut and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go
thank you to our audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleague
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
take care be safe and stay healthy
bye-bye now